o tac página da botou um ovo mandar não
podiam mil t do céu
hoje às 20 20 f é assim mesmo do relógio
do ben10 quebrou enquanto tavira monstro
e aí a gente vai treinar tudo com vocês
a minha obra de arte
ai ai mas olha só em 11 dias atrás eu
fiz uma boa chamada infância [__] pra
fazer essa música tive que pensar muito
sobre infância do que ano na cabeça sua
infância tive que pensar colocar no
papel da igreja levantei quase tudo que
eu podia ser uma infância e tal só que
eu apontei muito bem um assunto você que
a mulher não sabe tem um momento da vida
do cara que ele começa a descobrir o
próprio quinto pinto pinto é uma palavra
muito ridículo ao tem um forro europa ea
europa também muito equipe europa parece
uma espécie de motor de caminhão é e
quebrou nem programa rapaz estava
consertar um problema que foi na piroga
então o cara começa a descobrir eu acho
que tem só que tal problema porque o
problema não é quando ele descobre o
problema e depois que ele diz porque
depois que o cara descobre o irmão a
vida domingo no clube e me machucava
tanto sobre aceitar a função do meu
quarto engravidar a a reza a lenda se o
caso se masturbar sete vezes no mesmo
dia ele morria eu batia batia batia
batia com chegar na sexta parado pelo
seu regime bateu outro de animação ao
nosso complexo porque a mulher é a mesma
só se machucou segundo ela quer
completar um desejo sexual potência não
é toda hora que amanhã o marco é o amor
não se a fazer sair para comprar pão já
deu tempo ele bateu nela tem um povo que
fala um moinho na área de matemática uma
acção concertada espinha ao lançar a
pergunta participação na f1
a não porque o rosto tem tudo a ver com
a rua ea gente se cuida desses 15 pode
ter certeza que a maioria dos 1 no meio
da rua que o futebol acabaram muito nós
com certeza a pessoa com isso não podia
parar e falar pra mim e meu fim tão
sabendo morre há ainda a sua perna
[__] mata gente não tem nem
possibilidade de alguém morrer de bater
button o meu jogo 50 matar se eu to
filhos e até tivesse pelo menos metade
de habitantes que ela tem um tipo ia
matar seu canal tinha 10 mil inscritos
não passaram disso mesmo que a matasse
eu não estava aqui pra ver esse vídeo
você não estava impaciente esse vídeo o
seu pai estava em uma briga com cetáceos
esse vídeo de masturbação mas enfim aí a
pessoa assisto victor dinho fecha e no
click não gostei gente tem que ajudar
você ficando gostei e me ajuda muito a
primeira vez que você está aqui clique
no inscrever-se e toda vez que tiver de
novo você vai saber se vai dar esse
bicho galera eu quero investir estão
querendo comprar uma parada em outra um
toque mais mais legal que a loja ovi que
importa é ter um link que está em
primeiro aqui na descrição do vídeo você
ficando ele vai abrir o site da loja e
eles vão saber que você foi lá por causa
do meu vídeo então você está ajudando
por favor clique no link à descrição do
vídeo para o site dele tem lá umas
coisas legais que não estejamos perto
mas para tal também ajuda a compor essa
câmera e vídeo ao site a um dia da raiva
e 100 inscritos tem uma galera que quer
mandar um recado pra mim sculley eu te
deixar nossa gente para tênis pelos 100
mil inscritos
eu às vezes fico aqui na fortaleza da
solidão depois de uma missão depois de
ter que enfrentar o lex luthor que fica
enchendo o saco de metrópoles
eu coloco vídeos eu relaxo e está com o
trânsito aqui tem uns pingos que estão
aprendendo a dedicar à memória não tá
fácil pra ninguém
clinton então eu assisto dou risada
ficou mais tranqüilo mais relaxado super
feliz
um abração meu querido continua sempre
com esse bom humor que você tem um
abração do canela
hoje o inglês shan tudo bem meu querido
eu estou aqui para te dar os parabéns
você ter completado 100 inscritos e que
quer morrer isso de 500 gratuito aqui do
garoto 100 mil inscritos nossa 1
acredita que seja pelo funk é possível
que o garoto como você tem tantos
inscritos mais votar o benefício da
dúvida vou te dar um voto de confiança
moleque beijo e julho enquanto o bolinho
ana maria pra você tá
o enderson que remexe muito rebaixado
enquanto robert muito nós remexendo
enderson
eu vim aqui para falar de paz estão
sempre presente na boléia do meu capital
o novo optimus eu gosto de vingança
invenção parabéns por 100 mil inscritos
tenho certeza que entre eles deve ter
algum bom diz que também escuta em sua
cabine sua baleia o mesmo no seu rádio
mário gobbi tem rádio online
se bem que é na internet um e yo eu
tenho haifisch na boléia
beijo me liga